it is the nervous moment defying
everything drivers are taught No Hands
on the Wheel the first self-drive bus in
the world
Innovative sensors are doing the job of
humans guiding this nine ton single
Decker through the roads at 50 miles an
hour the initial route over the iconic
fourth road bridge between Fife and
Edinburgh
this is a strange experience usually
you'd be sitting down relaxing not
having to think about anything but you
can't help but look at every twist and
turn this bus is making that our members
of staff on board though a safety driver
sits in the cab monitoring proceedings
while another member of staff on board
looks after the customer experience
key member of the team as the safety
driver and that's driven by two reasons
so for legislation we need to have a
safety driving account and also where
there's elements of the route that the
technology will hand the control of the
bus back to the driver we must always
have a drive is that not defeat the
purpose though uh no because it's the
whole point of the car post project is
about enhancing the technology bosses
say there is global interest in this
Scottish product buyers standing by in
Dubai and Tokyo
and eventually as the technology matures
and develops it will become more
commonplace towards late 20s 30s 2040s
this may be transport innovation in
action but will passengers come looking
to get involved yeah amazing that's like
Back to the Future stuff I don't know if
I would go on that to be quite honest
I just don't know if I would trust it
technology is so Advanced but you just
never know this glimpse of the future
begins on Monday with pilot Services
carrying the first passengers on this
14-mile stretch Connor Gillis Sky News
near Edinburgh